in this video we're going to take a look
at the basic elements of subscriptions
within google play to better understand
how subscriptions work first of course
there is your app as well as your app
servers then there is the Google Play
Store on Android and Google Play server
api's the right column is built by you
the developer the left column represents
Google Play these columns can also be
separated by those elements on Android
and those elements on servers so both
you and Google have an Android element
and a server element now you know your
app interacts directly with your servers
but what about how you the developer
interact with Google Play on the Android
level this is done through the Google
Play billing library on the cloud level
communication is done through the Google
Play Developer API and Google cloud
pub/sub and those are the basic elements
of subscriptions on Play all of these
components work together to allow you to
have subscriptions within your app for
more information visit the link on
screen or check out our other videos
here